y es que la creciente escasez de energía
en china está provocando apagones en los
hogares y obligando a las fábricas a
reducir la producción lo que amenaza con
mermar la economía del gigante asiático
a las empresas que se encuentran en el
corazón industrial de ese país se les ha
dicho que limiten su consumo de energía
para poder así reducir la demanda además
de china y por motivos políticos tras el
proxy de reino unido vive una crisis de
combustible sin precedentes que afecta a
varios sectores del país esto hace
reflexionar sobre el futuro de la
energía cómo ser sostenible y cómo
pueden hacer los países para
democratizarla y no depender de solo una
fuente masiva de energía por eso quiero
darle entonces la bienvenida a nuestro
primer invitado del día el es arturo
carranza es consultor en temas
energéticos y director de proyectos de
energía de axa consultores gracias a
arturo por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa muy buen día con todo lo
que estamos viendo en china y también
reino unido- como ya lo comentaba antes
y hasta países de nuestra región que ya
están trabajando para buscar otras
fuentes de energía cuál será el futuro
claro muchísimas gracias por la
invitación
yo pondría en la reflexión sobre el
futuro del mundo en temas de transición
energética y de cambio climático la
relevancia o la importancia que tienen
las nuevas tecnologías para generar
electricidad me refiero particularmente
a la eólica y a la solar pero antes de
reflexionar sobre el papel de estas
tecnologías me gustaría compartirles
algunas ideas básicas con respecto a la
transición energética y su importancia
actualmente en este sentido empezaría
por comentarles que la transición
energética hoy en día tiene un papel muy
importante por la preocupación vinculada
con los efectos del cambio climático en
este sentido creo que es importante que
comentemos que el sector energético
aporta actualmente tres cuartas de la
semilla de tres cuartas partes de las
emisiones contaminantes de las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero en el
mundo y por lo mismo es clave para
evitar los peores efectos del cambio
climático un segundo elemento que o que
resalta la importancia de la transición
energética tiene que ver con los
compromisos de reducciones de gases de
efecto invernadero hay que recordar en
este sentido que próximamente se van a
reunir en
inglaterra los países en la cob 26 para
abordar el cambio climático si en esta
agenda de la cob 26
destacan algunos temas vinculados con la
necesidad de asegurar la reducción de
cero emisiones para 2050 y mantener al
alcance la meta de 1.5 grados
centígrados la necesidad también de
movilizar financiamiento y trabajar de
manera coordinada y conjunta las
diferentes naciones en todo el mundo
para lograr reducir los efectos de gases
de efecto invernadero ahora y por último
y de arturo para después seguir con la
conversación que tengo unos puntos
importantes que tocar con usted aclaro
me gustaría por último comentar que la
transición energética hoy en día es muy
importante porque las energías
renovables han reducido sus nada más
déjenme darles un dato muy preciso en
2020 un dólar invertido en proyectos
eólicos o solares generó cuatro veces
más rendimientos que un dólar gastado en
las mismas tecnologías hace diez años y
por eso la transición energética hoy en
día es muy importante ya puso entonces
los temas sobre la mesa de los cuales se
quiero conversar con usted arturo el
primero es esta transición energética
que usted de mucho ha hecho mención en
esta introducción a nuestro tema cómo
será esta transición qué tan difícil es
lograrla y además en nuestra región
también resaltando la eólica y la solar
que usted también lo comentaba el inicio
claro que sí me gustaría a partir de un
principio básico que está relacionado
con que la transición energética se está
presentando a nivel mundial en
diferentes velocidades las naciones
desarrolladas están instrumentando
planes muy ambiciosos agresivos
concretos para acelerar la transición
energética mientras que las las
economías en desarrollo las naciones
emergentes están teniendo algunas y de
los obstáculos que están partiendo de un
punto totalmente diferente al que parten
las naciones desarrolladas en este
sentido este hay que recordar la
necesidad de que en los países en
desarrollo como la región de américa
latina es necesario instrumentar una
serie de de apoyos muy concretos desde
el gobierno padre para poder hacerles
acelerar la transición energética en
materia particular en la región de
américa latina lo que yo observo es en
términos generales
y muy claro esfuerzo en la región para
impulsar la transición energética a
partir del impulso a las energías
eólica y solar principalmente yo veo de
manera general pero de manera admirable
lo que se está haciendo en chile que por
cierto en el último año ha visto
incrementar el la generación de energía
a través de fuentes solar más allá del
20 por ciento y la la eólica en la misma
medida un incremento anual superior a la
eólica más del 30 por ciento lo que está
haciendo chile es impresionante lo que
está haciendo colombia es igualmente
atractivo en términos de que está
próxima a lanzar una subasta en el mes
de octubre para impulsar la generación
de electricidad por fuentes limpias
colombia está trabajando está procesando
está por procesar una ley de acción
climática che de manera este para para
impulsar la energía y creo que en
términos generales podríamos hablar de
todos los países pero en términos
generales hay una conciencia
en américa latina' de la necesidad de
impulsar las energías limpias las
renovables para acelerar la transición
energética arturo es suficiente lo que
está haciendo la región para
contrarrestar con el cambio climático
que estamos viviendo además le quiero
preguntar cuál a su opinión es la más
sostenible la más amigable con el
planeta y la más fácil de implementar
también en cuestión de costos y teniendo
en cuenta nuestra topografía en nuestra
región andina
claro yo soy un convencido de que en
términos generales en la región se está
haciendo un esfuerzo formidable insisto
y avanzar en la penetración de las
energías renovables de los sistemas
eléctricos desde luego que hay áreas de
oportunidad muy importante de manera que
si analizamos país por país creo que
podríamos discutir cuáles son estas
áreas de oportunidad en este caso me
podría referir a lo que se está haciendo
en méxico gméxico cuenta con un
potencial extraordinario en materia de
recursos renovables el área de
oportunidad en este sentido estaría en
políticas gubernamentales que apoyen que
impulsen que fortalezcan que logre
aprovechar de una manera óptima
estas oportunidades y en cuanto a las
tecnologías que tienen un mayor futuro
yo podría decir que desde luego a nivel
global y en términos de la región la
solar y la eólica
arturo tenemos 40 segundos pero no
quiero que se nos escape la energía
nuclear qué opina sobre esto
desde luego que debe ser considerada en
el portafolio de proyectos de todos los
países es muy buena pregunta porque creo
que la transición energética debe
incorporar no solamente las energías
cuyos costos sean abatidos de manera más
clara en los últimos años se hizo solar
sino todas las energías al alcance de
los gobiernos y de las empresas la
energía nuclear en los últimos años ha
demostrado ser una energía muy limpia
muy eficiente uno de los retos que tiene
que están asociados a su generación ya
su consumo tiene que ver con los
residuos pero se ha avanzado mucho en
esta materia y desde luego que la
energía nuclear tuvo un papel
determinante pues arturo muchísimas
gracias un placer conversar con usted de
un tema tan interesante hacia dónde
vamos además y tan extenso me hubiera
encantado tener más tiempo pero
lamentablemente se nos agotó todo
gracias por su tiempo y por estar con
nosotros en directo american france24
feliz resto de día
muchas gracias a ustedes un saludo
saludo nosotros estábamos conversando
con arturo carranza consultor en temas
energéticos y director de proyectos de
energía en axa consultores